hello everybody and welcome back to
learning with Jackman X today I'm going
to be sharing with you something that
will elevate your Unreal Engine
cinematics and that is triggering
bespoke gameplay through the sequencer
Unreal Engine has been establishing
itself over the past few years as
something more than just being an engine
that you can use for games many people
use its cinematic tools to create
in-game cutscenes but also animations
and films within their own right but no
matter what you're using it for the best
way to get the most out of the engine is
to have complete control over what
happens throughout your cinematic so
let's learn how do we trigger bespoke
gameplay through the sequencer before we
dive on in I would just like to say this
tutorial would be be best suited for
people who have a base understanding of
blueprints and how to create functions
and events but first what is sequencer
sequencer gives users control over the
scene using level sequences within level
sequences users can add tracks and
create keyframes to manipulate objects
cameras and characters within this scene
in real time when we take a look at the
level sequencer we can see that it
offers us many options to manipulate our
digital environments for example we can
move objects we can turn their
visibility on or off we can even swap
materials and so much more but sometimes
these options are not specific enough
for our needs and that is where
triggering specific gameplay comes in
handy so enough jargon how do we do this
step one is to create a blueprint which
will store the logic that you want to be
triggered by the sequencer because the
sequencer cannot trigger any logic if
there is none there for it to trigger in
the first place the level sequencer has
the ability to bind to any tracked
blueprint actors functions or events
through using its event track and the
director blueprint it also has the
ability to manipulate custom variables
within its tracked blueprint actors so
keep this in mind when you're setting up
your blueprints we'll go through how to
do this in detail in The Next Step as an
example for this tutorial I'm going to
use a blueprint that I have previously
made of a phone this phone blueprint
actor has text that can get updated and
then goes up in little bubbles like
messages
and it also has a dots animation to make
it look like somebody is typing a quick
overview of what is within this phone
blueprint actor it has a widget
component which drives all the visual
logic this widget component references a
widget blueprint as its class and it's
within this widget blueprint that's all
the logic is stored within the widget
blueprint there is an event for a
animation to be played to mimic somebody
typing on the phone it's just the border
of dots that appear and disappear
it also has a function with a text input
parameter which will be used to update
an array of text messages which will
then be displayed on the screen the new
text from the input parameter gets
inserted to the top of the array pushing
the others down and index to have them
visually move upwards on the screen the
sequencer will not have access to the
widget class that the widget blueprint
is using on my phone actor blueprint
once I track it into the sequencer so I
have set up events on the phone
blueprint actor itself to cast to the
widget blueprint and call it event and
function so the two events on the phone
actor blueprint that I would like to
trigger via the sequencer are update
text message which will send a message
to the phone actor using a text input
parameter and don't and invisible which
will simply play an animation to
replicate somebody typing if that
already sounds a little bit intimidating
to you then just stick with me I'll walk
you through this I'll not dig too much
into the specifics of this blueprint
because really this video is about the
sequencer so just know if you have a
blueprint with an event or a function
that you want to call then that's great
that's all we need in this part if you
do want to learn more about how I made
this foam blueprint let me know in the
comments maybe in the future we'll dig
into a bit more
so once you have your logic up and ready
and you know it's working let's get that
triggered by the sequencer step two is
to create the sequencer and you know
what the best way for me to show you is
to actually do it myself and you can
follow so um come with me come with me
as you can see this is my little level
for my sequencer and here is the phone
actor itself if I open up the blueprint
of the phone actor I have my two events
here the update text message and the
dots and visible
and to test that these are working I'm
just going to hook up the dots and
visible and update text message events
on begin play so compile
and now if I hit play
I'll see the dots animation is working
and then I am a test message
okay so I know my events are working to
add a level sequencer to your level if
you have not already go to your content
browser and find the folder you want
your sequencer to be created in right
click and it will be under animation and
then look for level sequence down here
so left click on that one to create it
and then you can give it a name tutorial
sequencer
and once you have created this sequencer
you then left click and drag the level
sequence into your map and as we can see
I have tutorial sequencer here in my
world outliner now let's double click on
the level sequencer in the content
browser to open it up and you will see a
new tab be opened so there's nothing in
our sequencer yet and to change this I
can use this plus track button on the
left here an easy way to track a
specific actor into your sequencer is to
make sure that it's selected so click on
the actor that you'd like to track in
your editor you'll see in the outliner
it's also highlighted here and then back
in your sequencer you can click the plus
track button on the left and come down
to actor to sequencer and now note that
up the top it says add phone 01
blueprint which is my phone actor also
has everything else but because the
phone actor is selected it's at the top
it's very easy for us to find clicking
on that one I can see it's now within
the sequencer now another thing to note
here is that to preview gameplay that
needs the game to be running such as
widget animations then you also need to
have the sequencer to play When the Game
begins we can do this within the level
blueprint so if you come up to the top
of the editor you'll see this list of
world blueprints available to the user
click on that one and then there will be
open level blueprint click on this one
and you can see it's empty now I want to
have an event happen on begin play so
that it's triggered when the game plays
and I want to make sure that our
sequencer is played
so you can create a level sequence
player
and then we will need to
put in here what our level sequence is
that we would like to be played so mine
is tutorial sequencer so I've added that
one
here into the input parameter so now
we've got a level sequence player that
will reference our sequencer we then
need to play that so press play and
choose the movie scene sequence player
and then in the Target we just need to
hook it up to the out actor and that
will automatically get the sequence
player object reference
compile that one
and then when we hook up all of our
keyframes to trigger the logic in our
phone active blueprint we will actually
be able to see these animations uh when
we run the game because the sequencer
will automatically be played an
important thing to note though when you
do come to export your cinematic make
sure to unplug this logic alt left click
because your sequencer will actually
automatically Run the game when it
starts to export so you'll essentially
be running this level sequence twice and
your computer will be very unhappy
but I'll keep it hooked up for now
so back into our sequencer once you have
your actor tracked in the sequencer you
can see that there is another plus track
button next to the actor itself clicking
on that you can see that it actually
allows you some options to change it
already so I can add a transform and
change where it moves to
um I can even add a at a hidden track so
I can turn on and off its visibility
however what you might notice is that
the events that we have created are not
readily available to us and this brings
us on to step three how to bind to logic
in Blueprint via the sequencer so I'll
show you a few different ways of how to
trigger bespoke gameplay using the
sequencer number one is to control
blueprint variables through the
sequencer perhaps all you really need to
do is to change a variable on this actor
that isn't readily available for us here
this could be really useful if you want
to change a light intensity or a color
of an object or something like that so
going back to my phone example I am
using a material on the mesh
for the phone glass
and if I open up this one I'll browse to
it here and open it up
you can see that I'm actually using
scalar parameters within this material
there is a scalar parameter that
controls the emissive intensity by
multiplying the emissive color by it if
you don't know what material parameters
are they basically just allow users to
update the values within the material to
have it update without having to
recompile each time so let's say I want
to have this emissive intensity scalar
parameter to be controlled via the
sequencer so that I can have control on
how bright or dim the phone's glow is
this is actually pretty simple to do so
I'll go back into my phone blueprint
example and into my construction script
all I've got in here so far is a call to
get our widget components class
reference so from here we want to create
a dynamic material instance
so I'll click on this one
and the parent will be the material that
we want to create the dynamic material
instance of which is the phone glass
test
the one up here by creating a dynamic
material and not just getting the
material from the static mesh itself I
am then able to dynamically update any
of its scalar parameters so that's why
I'm doing this so I can set this one
promote it to variable just in case we
need in the future
uh call it screen material and then we
want to set this material to replace
the material on our phone
so if we go back to the viewports you
can actually see on our static mesh the
phone glass is element one we have two
different materials on here so let's go
into the construction script and we want
to swap out the elements one element
index one and of course we want to swap
it out with the dynamic instance of that
same material now because it's now
Dynamic I can actually get that material
reference and set scalar parameters
so I can hook this one up
and all I need to know is the parameter
name so if I go back to our material
just check the name emissive intensity
so we need to put in the parameter name
a missive
intensity
and now this value will drive the
emissive intensity
scalar parameter of our material
so it's zero let's compile and I can
check in my viewports yes it's gone dark
it's a dark dark phone it's got no
emission or a missive emissivity
uh so let's put it to 10 and see what it
looks like and there you go it's it's
nice and bright again so I'm gonna put
it somewhere in between I'll put it like
six
so this right here this value is what we
need to be updated by the sequencer so
let's right click on it and promote it
to a variable so I'm going to call it
a massive value
and in the variables details we need to
make sure that this variable is editable
so we can edit it outside of the
blueprint and we also want to click on
expose to cinematics
now this allows the sequencer to be able
to see this variable
so I'll hit compile again and go back
into our map and open the sequencer tab
then you should be able to see when you
track
on your actor there is your new value
under the properties section so I can
click on emissive value
and now a new track has been made for
the submissive value
now the emissive value is six that's
what we have set it as and you can move
this up and down
but as you can see we're not seeing the
phone change in editor right now
so to change this we can go back to our
blueprint
and go into our class settings of the
active blueprint and there is a little
tick box called run construction script
in sequencer so by default the
construction scripts always get run on
the actor being moved but we want it to
run when we make changes to it in the
sequencer so I've ticked on that one
compile go back to sequencer and there
we go that is super bright we don't want
166 emissive so let's uh put it back to
six here but as you can see we can make
it dark we can make it bright
and it updates in real time it's great
and we can keyframe that so we can
make it go from I don't know 6 to 100
and press play down here in our
sequencer and you can see
it gets very fast it gets brighter
so you can update a variable from a
blueprint actor but what if you want to
trigger an event or a function from the
sequencer this is useful when you once
control over more complex logic such as
my event to trigger the animation of the
dots appearing and disappearing to
trigger custom events and functions from
a specific actor blueprint we must click
on plus track again and actually add an
event track this time there's two
different types A trigger event track
and a repeater event track
but wait what even is an event Track
event tracks allow you to Define points
within your cinematic where you would
like to execute some scripted
functionality there are two options for
event tracks there's Trigger or repeater
a trigger event track is used to trigger
a specific event at a specified keyframe
within your level sequence a repeater
event track allows you to add sections
so that's the event is triggered every
time it's evaluated throughout those
sections so it can happen over multiple
frames and for my example I am using a
trigger event track
back to unreal
so for this example we're using triggers
so I've clicked on the trigger event
track and you can see it here events I'm
just going to close down this transform
so it's not as confusing so we have an
event track here for our actor blueprint
you can press the little plus button on
the right by it to add a new keyframe to
bind to an actor's events or function
using this keyframe you right click onto
it and then go into properties click on
Unbound next to the event and go into
Quick bind now we can see our active
blueprint is actually here so you want
to drop down onto that one and go into
class
then under class we'll have the name of
our blueprint and go into that one and
there you go these are all the available
events and functions that I have within
this blueprint so I'm going to bind to
my dots and I'm visible so that I can
trigger when to play that dots animation
once you have clicked on that event you
will have automatically created an event
endpoint and will be taken to the
director blueprint if you lose where
this is however you can always find the
directive blueprint Again by clicking on
this little button here in the sequencer
or alternatively you can right click go
into properties and you can actually
click on the little magnifying glass
next to your event
but what is a director blueprint each
level sequence has its own directive
blueprint and this blueprint holds the
logic for all of the events in the
sequence from this blueprint you can add
additional logic from the end points
that get created whenever you create a
trigger within your event Track event
endpoints are basically just events
within the director blueprint that are
triggered via an Associated keyframe
within the event track it's also
possible to create variables within this
director blueprint just like any other
blueprint and you can then pass on these
variables and other object information
to other active blueprints so basically
a blueprint for the sequencer so my
event endpoint is automatically Now set
up to trigger dots and invisible from
within my phone active blueprint if I
double click on it yeah it opens up the
blue for me and it tells me exactly what
event it is going to trigger
I can change things to do with this
event such as its name so I'm going to
change this to dots animation
back into our sequencer you can see now
that my keyframe actually has the dots
animation event name next to it before I
preview this and show you that I can
trigger this event via the second sir I
just need to go back into my foam
blueprint and make sure yeah
that none of it is being called on event
begin play so I'm not cheating it will
be the sequence of doing this now if I
press play you can see here that nothing
happens that is because as I explained
widget animations do not play without
the game actually running beneath the
game to run so
because we've set up our sequencer to be
played upon begin play in the level
blueprint this is fine we can just press
play on the game just so you know I like
to simulate whenever I make cinematics
but that's just my personal preference
um so I'll press play
and there we go we can see that the dots
animation is now playing which is very
nice
so I'll stop the simulation and just so
you know if you want to call that same
function again you can put another
keyframe on your events track right
click properties Unbound quick bind and
instead of going into your actor
blueprint like last time you can simply
click on this sequence and call function
because we have already created one in
the director blueprint and here it is
dots anim and there we go it is going to
call the exact same one and of course
you can always just select Ctrl C and
Ctrl v as well
easy peasy so delete these other ones
cool so what if you need to pass
information to your blueprint actor this
is helpful for when you need to update
some information as well as triggering
an event very much like my text message
event where I need to input what the new
text will say using the same method as
before I will create a keyframe right
click properties Unbound quick bind my
active blueprint go into class and then
choose update text message this is the
event for the text message click on this
one and then we'll go to our director
blueprint and as you can see it's a
little bit different this is because my
update text message event in my active
blueprint here actually is already set
up with an input parameter of a text
value so going back to my director
blueprint it is already set up up the
event endpoint with the same input
parameter that gets hooked up to the
event
super easy and I can then click on this
event and update it so I want this to
say text message so I know what the
input parameter is for and also I'll
just change its event name
okay compile come back to the sequencer
and right click on this keyframe that I
just set up and in its properties there
is a payload section down the bottom
with my input parameter variable
so in here I can put whatever I want
this is a text from sequencer
I'll hit enter
and there we go this keyframe has now
been updated with my input parameter so
again if I hit play I should now see
that the dots animation plays and then
yeah this is a text from sequencer all
happened quite quickly I can space them
apart a little bit
but there we go dots playing and then
this is a text from sequencer
I just want to note here that there
actually is a call in editor tick this
might work for some bespoke events but I
personally have never really found a use
for it as a lot of my bespoke events
just need the game to run for me to see
them so that's why I end up just playing
the sequencer when the game begins and
setting that up in my level blueprint so
I don't use this maybe you'll find it
useful
it's there the more you know and how to
create bespoke logic that is only within
your sequencer because what if you want
to trigger logic that doesn't already
live within another blueprint actor this
could be beneficial for you if you want
to add functionality that technically
could be a keyframe but is more
efficient to live within a event call so
you could for instance introduce a
visibility change after an event has
been called and do that within the same
event in my previous examples I was
binding to my phone blueprint actor and
triggering these two events update text
message and dots uninvisible as you can
see they both actually cast to a widget
blueprint called phone example this is
because we wanted to get a reference to
the widget class that our widget
component event was set up to be using
widget class here for an example however
we could also do this just as easily in
the sequencer
so let me show you how
go back to sequencer and actually I'm
going to look for our widget component
this time so I'm going to track my phone
blueprint
and I will look in the components
section and here is my widget component
click on that one
and then kind of indents it to show that
it's attached to the phone blueprint
actor I will click on the track for the
widget component this time and you can
see that it allows a lot of properties
to change but these are all generic
widget properties so it's nothing that I
have created within my widget blueprint
so what I need to do is I actually need
to make an event track for this widget
component so I'm going to make a trigger
a vent track again enter a keyframe and
then right click properties
Unbound and this time I'm just going to
create a new endpoint this is because if
I try to do what we did before I could
go into widget component but there is no
class option here
the sequencer simply cannot see what
class we have set the phone active
blueprint to use
so we need to find this out ourselves
let's create new endpoints and it will
take us straight to the director
blueprint in here it's not hooked up to
anything we haven't bound to any
function or event call yes but we do
have a widget component object reference
because we created this keyframe or
event endpoint on the widget component
event track from here I can actually get
the widget
components and then cast
to my wbp phone examples the wwbp is
just widget blueprint so for an example
and then hook these up here now this is
going to get a reference to the class
that I'm using
and in the class is where my events and
functions are stored so I want to
promote this to a variable so I can
reference it in the past and now as you
can see it's promoted to a variable just
like any other blueprint and it will
stay here for me to use whenever I would
like to and now that we've got this
available to us I can search for any of
its functions or events so if I search
dots visible there you go it will now
call
this event here
in my widget blueprint actor
so go back to the director blueprint if
I left the event like this it would
basically replicate what this dot
animation event is doing because the
dots animation event is going into my
phone actor it's casting to find the
widget blueprint reference and it's
calling dots visible and then if you
look here that's exactly what we're
doing here as well so let's have a bit
of fun and see what else I can do in the
sequencer what if I want to show someone
is typing before they actually then send
a message so I'm going to use both of
the events that are readily available
for us so we'll play the dots visible
and then I want to create a timer by
events I will have this time be an input
variable so I'm just going to drag it
to our custom events and then let go and
they go we've made a input variable and
I'm going to call this delay time
so this will allow some time for the
animation to play I want to add a custom
event
called animation finished or whatever
timer finished whatever you want to call
is I guess timer finish would probably
make a bit more sense
and and then I want to play my second
event
update text
there it is so update text is the same
call as update text message because
again in my phone active blueprint it's
just getting the class and then calling
update text
and back in the director blueprint we
have already gotten a reference to our
widget blueprint and we're calling
update text now again we need to have
this be an input variable so we can call
what's the update text message is here
so text message
and if we can pile yeah that should
break
so it's a little bit spaghetti right now
we can double click and clean them up a
little bit one thing to note is that
casts can be pretty expensive there you
go no this will cause a blueprint to
always be loaded which can be expensive
so once you already have done a cast
then you don't need to do it anymore
because we've already got the reference
to our widget blueprints so I can get
this one and then right click on it and
convert to valid get and then I can just
look to see whether we already have this
or not if we do have it then we can just
carry on and um
use uh
use our events as normal if we don't
have it then yeah we'll have to cast to
it
but casting once is much better than
casting every single time
and there we go now we have
uh dots I'm gonna change this name to
widget dots and message
now we have a event that we have created
from scratch in the director blueprint
to show you that the director for
blueprint can have variables you can
create bespoke logic in here you can do
casting you can basically do anything
that you would want to do in other
blueprints in the director blueprint
here
so compile go back to the editor and
then right click properties and here
I've got my delay time input and my text
message input so I'm going to make the
delay time be
four seconds and then I am going to put
my text message as
hi I'm a text from
the widget
yeah
enter
and I'm going to delete
my event calls from the phone actor
because I don't want them getting in the
way
and when we play
it should do this for three seconds four
seconds I can't remember how long hi I'm
a text from the widget
there we go and now I can have multiple
of these if I would like to I could put
um on the phone actor event graph I can
have my call to
uh just add a bunch of messages so text
message trigger yes yes yes yes
uh I'm a message
in a bottle of baby
yes
and then I'll copy and paste and do
another one
um
Gotta Type
me before
bed I I don't know
and then um hopefully they should you
should all run I'm a message in a bottle
Baby Gotta Type before bed hi I'm a
Texoma widget
so that did work
um it still did the four second delay
and it texted out all my other messages
as well and there you have it now you
know how to manipulate the sequencer to
bow down to your bespoke demand and as
always if there's anything that I have
missed about sequencer or director
blueprints then please do let us all
know in the comments as always I'd like
us to be a place of shared information
and learning because just like you I am
learning every day as well but all of
these tips I have shared with you today
have really really helped me make my
cinematics music videos films whatever I
do using the sequencer I always always
find a use to trigger some bespoke logic
and if you have any questions at all
please pop them in the comments below
I'll do my best to answer them but who
knows maybe someone in the community can
also Pew as well it's safe to say this
is my first non-beginner tutorial I know
blueprints can be a bit intimidating
when you first start working with them
especially if you don't have any
programming experience beforehand but if
you stuck with me then thank you I hope
you learned something and I hope it all
made sense there is a written version of
this tutorial on medium so I will leave
a link to that in the description down
below and I want to say a massive thank
you to my patreons who really help me
make this type of content that always
keeps supporting me everything you do
just really helps so thank you thank you
so very much if you'd also like to
support me the patreon link is in the
description as well and yeah I think
that's about it so until my next video
thank you so much enjoy creating
whatever you're creating I wish you the
best of luck with all your projects and
I'll see you very soon
have a lovely day evening bye
[Music]
sorry